à paris où l'éclipsé était presque total
99 4%
plusieurs centaines de milliers de
personnes ont aussi chausser leurs
lunettes sur les champs-elysées la tour
eiffel ou la butte montmartre 2000
policiers avaient été déployés les
services du samu et des pompiers mise en
alerte
fort heureusement tout s'est bien passé
et on a même tourné en dérision les
prévisions apocalyptiques de paco
rabanne commentaires et les nuques avec
les équipes de reporter d'image de la
rédaction la ville lumière sous
d'éblouissantes ténèbres mais
l'apocalypse annoncée par paco rabanne
n'a pas eu lieu
les la station mir n'est pas tombé et
paris ne s'est pas enflammé quelques
centaines de manifestants ont fêté les
erreurs de prophétie du couturier
parrain très ironique apéritif des
survivants partout ailleurs dans la
capitale on a ignoré les prédictions
catastrophistes le spectacle d'abord
derniers préparatifs dernière
distribution de lunettes mouvementée à
la villette
nous aimons gradés la main ce moment
chacun part alors à la recherche de la
meilleure place entre deux nuages les
spéculations vont bon train
ça va être maligne qui va venir en
première mais en fait du monde à iquique
c'était soleil
que le spectacle commence l'astre mort
grignote lentement l'astre de feu à
paris c'est me 186 minutes durant le
soleil et la lune se disputent les
monuments
m
à 12h22 l'éclipsé est à son maximum
99 4% l'obscurité ne sera pas plus
intense paris s'éblouit j'avais jamais
vu des clipse les plus de temps qu'est
ce que je suis c'est ward s'est loupé la
première chose je peux avoir je peux
retourner ce que vous prêts car chaque
seconde compte est les spectateurs de
l'équipe je savais bien la
représentation serait unique